Oh
I don't know about you but sex is always
potentially extremely troubling it can
cause all sorts of ruckus and all sorts
of lives on on an endless basis just
look at the latest politician or golfer
and the fact is that that because of its
power which Darwin understood when he
saw that sexual selection was the engine
of natural selection which is what
creates species you you have to have
some sort of rules about it otherwise
it's simply too massive for one thing
men and women have different
reproductive strategies as we call them
in my trade because the costs of sex
unprotected sex for females are
infinitely different than for males and
so there always has to be in any
community the basic mammalian contract
which is that somebody has to take care
of the mother-child bond and so if you
look at kinship systems basically what
they do is try to ensure that the mother
and child are cared for by the community
this is after all the story of Christmas
basically it's the great mammalian fable
or story and it works perhaps the most
popular holiday in the world because it
gets right to the bedrock of what
religion is about which is you've got to
take care of the mother and the child
it had a chastity has a purpose if
you're setting up a church in which you
don't want to interfere you don't want
sex to interfere with the church
activity so for example if you're if
you're a cardinal you don't want to have
a bunch of mistresses around or if
you're a chief none you don't want to
have a bunch of guys who are your lovers
because that interferes with your work
it's very simple and now chastity is
usually respected only to the point of
marriage and so with marriage suddenly
it all changes you're supposed to be
chaste and then at marriage suddenly you
have sexual obligations so a woman had
sexual obligations to their husband and
husband had sexual obligations to his
wife and so the system is very aware of
the relationship between sexuality
license and responsibility